Russia has not adhered to the agreement
they should have been done years ago
until people come to their senses we
have more money than anybody else by far
we'll build it up until they come to
their senses when they do then we'll all
be smart and we'll all stop and we'll
and by the way not only stop will reduce
the treaty in question the INF or the
intermediate range nuclear forces treaty
of 1987 it restricts what kind of
nuclear weapons can be constructed it
essentially outlaws short-range and
intermediate range nuclear weapons
nuclear missiles from being constructed
it was signed back in 1987 it was seen
as a key moment in ending the Cold War
de-escalating the conflict between the
USA and the Soviet Union now we know
John Bolton is at this moment in Russia
he has already met with the Russian
Foreign Minister as well as the Russian
National Security Council he is speaking
rather vaguely about the possibility of
a new treaty being negotiated and he
isn't exactly clear on what the United
States is going to do he's not using
that bold type of language that we were
hearing from Trump the United Kingdom
has spoken up in support of this action
by the United States saying the USA is
right to make this move but throughout
the European Union we are hearing a
disappointment with this statement we
hear different you countries represented
opposing this action and referring to it
as regrettable let's take a listen to
some of what's been said we regret the
withdrawal announcement by the u.s. we
see this treaty is a very important
instrument of arms control and one that
serves European interests and therefore
German interests as well it has also
become clear this weekend that NATO will
have to address the issue thoroughly
including at the upcoming meeting next
week Germany will actively contribute to
the discussion because we stand in favor
of the preservation of this treaty and
we stand for a work in design in
mechanism in Europe that is our goal we
hope the USA will avoid withdrawing
believe that the US and Russia need to
remain engaged in constructive dialogue
to preserve the treaty and to ensure
that it's it to ensure its full and
verifiable implementation which of
course is crucial
for Europe's and global security so the
fact that a thirty-year-old treaty is
now in question a treaty that was key
and ending the Cold War and the nuclear
arms race this points to a rising level
of tension between the United States and
Russia
darío revolta a former Italian MP and
international relations analyst says
Trump won't listen to Europe as he's
looking to his own country's midterm
elections all the voice are agreeing all
of them are on the same way the fact is
that mr. Trump looks to be less
attentive to what European are thinking
about and so I'm not so sure that
European a voice or the voice of the
different European countries can
convince him to to get back we have to
add one another thing that most probably
the real reason for which Trump made
that statement is due to the midterm
elections that he are going he is going
to have in beginning November and I
think that more than a for international
reason it was at you two internal
reasons that the decision the decision
of Americans arrived
you